okay it disgusts me that at this stage
of the game I have to do this story
today but I have to do this story today
it appears that multiple states are pick
your poison having issues lying
falsifying distorting coronavirus
testing case and or death numbers and
there is no doubt that this is affecting
our understanding of how effectively we
are dealing with coronavirus in the
United States in a bunch of different
parts and the reason why this is just
sickening is last week I came to you and
I said listen guys I don't know why but
there are some closed states states that
have been shut down for months that are
doing really no better than some states
that have opened wouldn't it be amazing
if states really could reopen without
seeing spikes maybe that's possible
except now with all of these allegations
of bogus numbers and dishonest numbers
and suppression of numbers it becomes a
lot more difficult to know what's really
going on so here's the deal and some of
these individual components we've
already talked about in the past one
example was Georgia Georgia had reopened
really early started on I believe it was
April 24th their numbers didn't really
look too bad they used that data to
justify continuing to reopen other
states said look at what's going on in
Georgia we can justify reopening Georgia
officials now admit that they had
processing errors processing errors
which made it look like infections were
declining when they actually were not
that data that three times had so-called
errors was what they used to justify
reopening more and more and more when in
reality the numbers were far worse than
they were publicizing that's Georgia
Florida Florida I already told you about
the situation where cause of death was
being suppressed for a while which was
artificially holding down coronavirus
deaths I told you last week about this
data model or sort of tech person who
was pushed out slashed fired we still
don't have the full explanation after
she said I'm not going to fall
safai data which was what she was
allegedly told to do that's Florida
Arizona Arizona has become one of the
most open States and they have also
become one of the fastest spiking states
on a percentage basis they cut off a
team of health service experts who were
modeling the state data it wasn't
looking great instead Arizona decided
the governor Republican governor said
hey you know what let's use the federal
government modeling data which of course
is much more optimistic and much more
easily usable to justify reopening
although it is not reflective of what is
actually going on in Arizona then we
have this other story where the CDC and
11 different states have been sometimes
combining when they report tests they're
combining infection and antibody tests
which dramatically increases the testing
rate on paper reduces the positive rate
on paper it doesn't actually reflect how
many people are catching the virus and
how many active infections there are
it's absolutely insane that this has
been done and this includes Colorado
Delaware Georgia Maine Mississippi
Missouri New Hampshire Pennsylvania
Texas Vermont and Virginia all mixing
infection and antibody tests at one
point in their reporting some of the
states have since fixed this that
includes places like Vermont and
Virginia unclear which other states have
fixed this in which other states
continue to do this when we have a
situation like in Pennsylvania we are
also dramatically under Counting what
the severity of the widespread infection
is because Pennsylvania is not providing
full data on cases and deaths from
nursing homes nursing homes nationally
have been huge hotspots of infection in
Massachusetts at one point 50 or 60
percent of the deaths were in nursing
homes
imagine if Massachusetts said yeah we'll
report data except from nursing homes
you'd think the outbreak was only half
as bad Nebraska at one point told meat
packing plants you don't have to report
your cases and the governor wrote it off
and said well that's a business decision
now it's a public how
decision and it's one that is
propagandizing the premature opening of
states so we've sunk lower than low we
are doing in bits and pieces what Trump
slams China for doing not telling the
truth about cases and deaths and it's
happening right here all Americans
should be outraged period this borders
China aside this borders on the
totalitarian type rewriting a reality
type nonsense that we claim to be
opposed to we now simply cannot really
believe that we are doing better or that
some states are doing better because
we're not getting accurate information
it is being suppressed to justify
reopening in many states how dare we say
how dare China cover up the numbers when
we're doing the exact same thing and
they do not care we continue to see
protests without masks we continue to
see a lack of social distancing we
continue to see full bars and
restaurants often immediately within 30
minutes of states lifting some elements
of the stay at home orders this is a
time where you know listen Massachusetts
has not been perfect there's no doubt
Charlie Baker was not the fastest but he
was much faster than a lot of other
states this is a place where you know
when I look at the data here in
Massachusetts number one I can
reasonably trust the data there is
transparency about nursing home deaths
there's transparency about testing
numbers the curve looks good we have now
been under a hundred deaths for a whole
bunch of days or you know 95 percent of
a whole bunch of days the curve is
reversing testing is being ramped up
this is one of those times where I am
genuinely glad to live in a state that
is at least somewhat tethered to truth
and reality it's not been perfect it's
certainly not been perfect but what is
happening in some of these states is
borderline criminal in the sense that it
is distorting it is public information
govern state government releasing
information that is wrong to justify
policies and actions that lead to more
people in the hospital more people in
ICUs and more people
and you know all of these dishonest
players Trump at the top but people at
the state level people at local levels
they all must suffer the consequences
for their participation
in this we're going to keep covering
this on Instagram at David Pakman show I
did something funny I posted a picture
of me pre quarantine and now to my
Instagram David Pakman I barely
recognize pre quarantine me it's
shocking how much my physical appearance
has changed during the quarantine check
it out at David Pakman we'll take a
quick break and we have so much more
coming up for you this episode is
sponsored by Blu Chu one of the things I
make a priority on the show is not to
perpetuate stigma for things that don't
deserve it we've talked about mental
health we've talked about many things
where we should all just be respectful
adults period and we would be better off
and Blu true can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for blue to calm blue
like the color blue is the first
chewable with the same fda-approved
ingredient as in Viagra and Cialis it
can be taken day or night even on a full
stomach since it's chewable it works
twice as fast as a pill whenever the
opportunity arises blue chew is
prescribed online by licensed doctors
you don't have to go to a doctor's
office you don't have to wait in line at
a pharmacy it ships right to your door
in a discreet package they're made in
the USA and since blue 2 prepares and
ships direct it's cheaper than a
pharmacy and best of all no more
awkwardness we've got a special deal for
our viewers and listeners go to blue to
comm get your first shipment free when
you use our promo code Pakman that's PA
que ma n Pages $5 shipping that's blue2
dot-com promo code Pakman to try it
totally free blue chew is the better
cheaper faster choice and we thank them
for sponsoring the David Pakman show